In this video, we'll dive deeper into Triangle Count.
Looking more at Triangle Count, as we just saw, various DCC and CAD applications have
their own ways of processing geometry, some of which allow more control over the density
of your mesh, while others do not.
You should always keep your Triangle Count in check, especially if you do not plan on
using Nanite.
LODs, or levels of detail, can be generated in your DCC tool or automatically by Unreal
Engine simply by selecting an LOD group or by specifying a number of LODs.
The idea behind LODs is that you will see higher poly, more detailed versions of a model
as you are closer to it and it takes up more screen space and a simpler, less triangle dense
version of your model as you get farther away and its space on the screen becomes smaller.
The more LODs you have, the heavier your geometry will be, especially in terms of its RAM usage,
so take care with deciding how many that you actually need.
Note that while you're testing in Unreal Engine, you can temporarily disable certain LODs or
even set a minimum LOD to determine what's actually necessary for your scene.
Here we can see in LOD settings the opportunity to set the number of LODs that we have, as
well as the decimated percent of Triangles that we are going to see.
So for example, if our mesh had 10,000 Triangles, then at this level we'd be seeing 8,500 Triangles.
Don't forget to always apply your changes after you've adjusted.
And note that we have a Mesh LOD coloration view mode that actually will show different
LODs as different colors.
When fine-tuning these parameters, consider the details that need to be viewed on distant
objects and what is not as necessary.
And also feel free to consider adjusting the advanced option of the screen size, which
will affect when we make a switch from one LOD to another.
If you are using a platform that can support it, Nanite is the newest Unreal Engine 5 technology
able to handle millions of polygons without breaking a sweat.
It does this by determining what's actually visible at a per pixel level and never drawing
more Triangles than what's actually needed.
Here we can see a comparison of the same scene with and without Nanite.
Without Nanite, Unreal Engine has to process 5.8 million Triangles, whereas with Nanite,
that becomes reduced to just 16.7 thousand.
As we've already seen, in Unreal Engine 5.6, most new geometry that gets imported has Nanite
enabled by default.
However, there are plenty of opportunities to toggle Nanite on and off.
You can do this sometimes in the import dialog or just by right clicking on an object and
choosing Nanite enabled or disabled here, or when you're opening, for example, the static
mesh window, you also have access to toggle Nanite on and off there.
Once again, it will not apply until you apply your changes.
Let's take a brief look at the Nanite scene in the project, which can be found under Maps
and Nanite.
Here we can see a building as well as a more natural rock formation.
And if we type in stat RHI, which can also be found up here under viewport stats RHI,
we can see that we're currently drawing between 13 and 16 million triangles.
Now let's try enabling Nanite.
We'll do it one at a time.
We can open up SM Cliffs by finding it in the browser here and just go to Nanite, hit
the checkbox or hit enable.
And this will take a moment to process.
And while the rock looks the same, we now see a drop in the total number of triangles.
Let's try the same thing with the building, which can be tricky because as we can see
here, this building is made up of lots of individual parts.
So what we want to do is we want to find the top level of classic building, find it over
here, and then that entire geometries folder is going to want to be set to be Nanite.
So we can control A to select all of them, choose Nanite, and say enable Nanite on all
44 meshes.
We don't have to save it right away.
We can test to see if it's doing what we expected to in our scene as all the geometry
reloads.
And we can see as this is happening, a significant reduction in our triangles drawn.
We're now down to only 7,000.
And yet, we can see all the detail is maintained.
We can see this in our viewport by going to Nanite visualization triangles.
And we can see the way that these triangles change as we get closer and further away for
a cleaner view, type stat RHI again to remove that window.
And we can see the way that Nanite, automagically, handles real time LOD without needing to manually
set anything else up.
In the next video, we'll examine how various DCC tools handle scene hierarchies and how
best to preserve them in Unreal Engine.